- Nick Jonas is literally my daddy.
Yes, he's so hot and he
sings so good fucjajsj.
I can tell you this, I'm
definitely not your daddy.
I'm 100% sure of that.
100% sure.
(upbeat music)
Hey it's Nick Jonas and today
I'll be reading thirst tweets.
Let's get to it.
This is the LOL Bucket.
The first tweet of thirst is:
Dear Nick Jonas, you literally
make me want to set myself
on fire from your immense sexiness.
So if you could dial it down a bit.
K, thanks.
Listen here.
Can't dial it down.
That's bananas.
I want Nick Jonas to star
star star the absolute
star star star out of my star
star star star star star.
Star.
What's a star?
I'm gonna get Nick Jonas's face tattooed
on my left ass cheek so I can say
I sit on Nick Jonas's face all the time.
That's pretty clever, actually.
Which facial expression would
you like to have tattooed?
This one...
Please hold.
Or this one.
I think the second, cause
then maybe the other thumb
will come up depending on
what you're doing back there.
Gab says Nick Jonas could
choke me on any holy day.
Into choking, huh?
Makes two of us.
Nick Jonas, eat bacon off my naked body.
I don't know.
It might not be the cleanest
surface to eat bacon off of.
Usually I go for a plate,
or perhaps a cheeseburger.
Maybe after a shower or
something we can talk about it,
work something out.
I have this recurring fantasy now
where Nick Jonas puts
me between his thighs
and crushes my body.
(laughs)
I do have very strong thighs.
Probably not strong enough to
crush your entire body though.
But we can give it a try,
if you really want to.
Nick Jonas can bite my
nipple and snatch it
out of my body and I'd say thanks daddy.
That's an odd...
Bite my nipple and
snatch it out of my body.
That makes no sense whatsoever.
Nick Jonas is so hot I can feel
it radiating in my kneecaps.
My dad used to say that about the weather.
He'd say oh I think a storm's coming,
I can feel it in my kneecaps.
But not about you know,
Farrah Fawcett's hair or something.
Used different lingo regarding that.
Nick Jonas could literally
rip me to shreds.
Interesting.
I think I know what you're talking about.
I'm pretty sure I get the innuendo there.
Rip you to shreds.
Interesting.
That's all the thirst tweets.
I have a few more in my direct messages
that I could show you at a different time
but that's for the R-rated version.
For now this has been
thirst tweets with me,
Nick Jonas.
Peace.